here in this video we shall try to get
to the bottom of a very ancient question
one that has been floating around for
millions of years and that is which is
the most powerful dinosaur in the
jurassic franchise is it the spinosaurus
the indominus rex or the giganotosaurus
sorry rexy fans but these three dinos
have defeated the t-rex in their
separate appearances in the jurassic
franchise but they haven't faced each
other so let's get down to solving this
question
we shall first take a look at their
battles and we will be assessing their
powers by watching them battle with the
t-rex let's start with the first dino vs
dino the spinosaurus t-rex battle as you
can see in jurassic park 3 the battle
was shot lasting for roughly 30 seconds
even though the t-rex got the first bite
on the neck of the spiner the ladder was
undoubtedly more powerful and shrugged
off it was also unfazed by the headbutts
of the t-rex and then it delivered a
neck-breaking bite of its own with the
help of its longer hands holding onto
the wrecks as it snaps it killing the
t-rex instantly
then we shift to the next battle between
the big carnivals the t-rex was released
from its enclosure in the wake of the
indominus rex causing chaos in the park
the two squared off against one another
and it would be the first time the irex
faced off against another apex predator
the bell lasted for around 40 to 50
seconds just under a minute and although
rexy initially got the upper hand in a
shock attack the irex counter-attack and
pummeled the t-rex into submission but
just before it was about to deliver the
killing blow blue the raptor intervened
and turned the tide of the battle in
rexy's favor
and so in the latest confrontation the
t-rex and the giganotosaurus fought in
the newly released prologue for jurassic
world dominion they kinda had this short
face-off with them walking around kind
of like an intimidation display and
roared at each other the t-rex tried to
get into the giga's neck but the gigger
fended off that attack with a headboard
of its own they smashed into one another
struggling with a scene showing the giga
nearly falling off into a ravine but
then in a short time the giganotosaurus
got the upper hand bit the t-rex's neck
and maybe it would have snapped it like
the way the spino did and yieted the
t-rex into the ravine sealing the fate
of rexy in a measly 22nd battle
now let's assess the advantages and
disadvantages for each dinosaur starting
with the spinosaurus it was undoubtedly
the biggest carnivore in the jurassic
franchise being about 52 feet long and
weighed eight tons its main advantage
against t-rex was its speed agility and
size as well as its longer forearms
which it used to deadly effect while
snapping the buck t-rex's neck it would
have had more advantage if the battle
was near a water source because it is a
semi-aquatic species the main
disadvantage though is the big sail like
spine which would be a big target and a
vulnerable area for bites
now the indo wrecks advantages and
disadvantages well the disadvantages for
this hybrid is few and far in between i
could not think of one as it is created
for to be a perfect predator but i could
see that it would be vulnerable around
water sources and swamps as it was
killed by the mosasaurus its main
advantages would be its high
intelligence owing to the fact that it
has wrapped the genes in it it could
camouflage and blend to any surrounding
therefore making it a perfect ambush
predator it also has tough skin and a
pair of longer forearms and a jaw that
could deliver a powerful bite force due
to the genes of the t-rex infused in it
and lastly the giganotosaurus well not
much is known about this dino except for
the fact that it is bigger than the
t-rex so it would have been between 45
and 50 feet long it also has bigger
forearms but not by much as compared to
the irex and the spinosaurus it does
however have a tough semi-armored skin
which we can see by its big osteodomes
on its back and scaly crocodilian skin
it also has a powerful bite force with
serrated dagger-like teeth it might also
have the added characteristic of brute
strength as seen with it killing the
t-rex in 20 seconds and kicking it to
the curb afterwards
so in conclusion all three dinosaurs are
extremely powerful and hence why ranking
them is so difficult but judging by the
battle against the t-rex and the giga
took the lead with a win in under 20
seconds as compared to 30 for the spino
and around 50 for the irex but if we
look at the advantages and disadvantages
comparison the indominus rex takes the
lead in many areas such as intelligence
camouflage and overall flexibility the
spiner takes to win for size and would
be king if any battle is fought near a
swamp or a water source but overall i
would have to say that in an open field
battle or an arena-like condition where
there's no external factor
that would help one or the other i think
that the indominus rex would win the
fight against either the spinal or the
giga and i think that the spiner would
win against the giganotosaurus so there
we have it the irex then the spino then
the giganotosaurus then t-rex
and so with that we come to the end of
the video do hit that like button for
support and click on that subscribe
button as well to be a part of the mind
care family but most of all smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam